[Music]
i rule
[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode kos
and today i bring you a statue
that is uh often misunderstood and um
they finally got a chance to get it
right
today i bring you the she-hulk
from xm studios
wow an incredible statue
but before i go any further let's talk
about
the she-hulk in the beginning
she was known as the savage she-hulk
and this is one of my favorite books
because you know it has
old school uh iron man tony stark
and um and it has the she-hulk
a lot of y'all don't know who the
she-hulk is the she-hulk
is actually the cousin of
dr david bruce banner the incredible
hulk
now how she came to be was jennifer
walters
which is her oh um well you could say
being that she spends most of the time
as a she-hulk i guess
jennifer walters is her alter ego
um and they changed their hair color but
i'm getting ahead of myself let me let
me go into her past
uh she's a successful lawyer and uh she
prosecutes
uh you know mafia criminals and stuff
of that nature well her cousin was
visiting her
one day and uh the hulk
and the mob put a hit out on her
she got shot and uh you know he rushed
to he rushed into action
he took her inside a building and she
was bleeding
out and in order for her to survive
he had to give her some of his gambling
radiated blood
well we all know how that turned out
she turned into the she-hulk uh
you know and you know beat off the the
mobsters
but for a long time
they didn't know what to do with her see
because
you would think that uh if you have one
of your
most uh iconic characters
uh most successful characters all you
have to do
is to make a female character you can
bring in a female demographic
it doesn't work like that the savage
seahawk
as you can see from her clothing
here all it was was
just a white ripped up shirt and i know
it works for the incredible hulk with
the purple pants
but you have to do a little bit more
so when her unsuccessful run
came to an end of the sabbath she-hulk
[Music]
john byrne which is probably
one of my best
artists because he knows how to make
splash pages he knows
and a splash page is when you you take a
character and you fill out the page
with that character and all eyes on that
character
well when john byrne took his hand at
writing a drawing uh
she-hulk he turned her into the
sensational she-hulk
this is that iconic face portrait
that we have here with the full hair
she's fully realized as you can see she
has a track suit and stuff like that
it changed how she looked he kept the
white and the green
but added a little bit of purple you
know for the incredible hulk because it
works so well with them
so that's when the book took off that's
when she had a personality
she stayed the she-hulk uh most of the
time
after i don't even remember when's the
last time she turned back to jennifer
walters
to be honest with you and um she had
like a hair change
because for a long time i i thought her
hair was black and then i went back and
i read
issue one all the way up to like issue
20 i'm
i just took six for a reason but up to
issue 20
and uh yeah her hair was that color so
basically he changed her around
and made her his own
so let's get into the statue this statue
comes with two different head scopes and
i think
this head sculpt here
is the softer one with the the nice hair
it's a little bit laid down um
i personally uh love
the john burns scope that's the first
issue of the sensational she-hulk
she comes out with two switch-out arms
one with a finger pointing straight out
one arm and the bent arm
well she's standing on a hydra tank
and if you look at the tank
the tank is tore up she's she she ripped
it up she showed her strength
the paint scope is beautiful it's
immaculate everything is in line
the hair is very intricate and you can
see
details of black with green
a little bit of highlights inside
and i love the s curl in the front
from like when he was doing superman
john byrne has that way she looks strong
she looks robust at the same time being
feminine and it is it's a hard thing to
do with statues because you you run that
line
of showing off the strength and showing
off the femininity
in the character and she eloquates
all of that hair i love how the hydra
tank is ripped off and she has the front
at the top
and she's crushing it this is a very
very heavy base
i didn't think it was going to be this
heavy i was uh
very surprised when i got it oh guess
where i
got it from i got it from spec fiction
where you guys should go to their
website and give them a shot
check them out uh tell them the king
sent you
and hopefully they'd be like who's he
but anyway this is where i got it from
and it's a it's a great statue and i'm
so happy to have on my collection
well this is the part in the video when
i'm gonna ask you
to like follow and subscribe and hit the
joy button
hit that join button you know where that
join button is
that join button is right there at the
bottom so when you join the realm you
get a chance to win a
playstation 5 at xbox series x
we have those sweepstakes going on also
go to lords of gaming.net
where we have a ton of writers doing
everything
up to the minute about gaming news
all the news that you need to know in
the tech industry as the console world
and also uh the video game world all
that information is
up and ready for you at the click of a
button to be honest with you
also you can go get old episodes of kos
also look at lore cognito and ibontis
with the last word destiny november 10th
is going to be crazy right now i think
we have the festival of the lost going
on
that's the halloween special i'm gonna
go right upstairs right now
because i gotta get that horror story
done
catch me at iop sundays
at 11 a.m during football season oh
god football season but also you can
catch me at dog castle x
on fridays at 9 00 pm when we talk
statue stuff
like we doing now so
see you next week when i bring you
a statue that's out of this world hey
stick around watch this statue
the unboxing in all its glory
stay collected
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
by this
[Music]
you